で もしかするとウパーダーナですね
そうすると 六番目のガンタ
チャッターロ・ガンタ・アビッジャー・カーヤ・ガントー・ヴェーパード・カーヤ・ガントー・シーラッブタ・パラマーソ・カーヤ・ガントー
ウダン・サッチャーニ・ディ・ニヴェーソ・カーヤ・ガントー
で これもこの不善心臓のある一部
特別な働きで説明しているんです
不善心所は五順の中でね
十4ありますからね それは基本的には説明して終わりましたけど
一つ一つの心所が時々いろんな働きをしてくれる
ですから そこら辺は本当に心の問題があるんだと
そういうことでこれからの説明は続けています
わかりやすく言えば 欲がありますよ
欲がありますよと言っても
一般的な社会ではそんなわかってはないんです
ただ欲一色だと思っているんですね
でも仏教で欲っていうのは対象を自分の方に引っ張ること
美味しいものだ いいものだと
その引っ張ること自体が時々いろんな働きをする
いろんな違う働きをして
我々の存在の輪廻の苦しみの問題を作る
ですから それでこの働きによってまた同じことを繰り返して説明している
で この前説明したように
このオーガとかね ヨーガとか
そういうふうな働きもして
輪廻転生 輪廻に束縛してくる
で 今日の働きはガンタ
ガンタっていうのは あの
結ぶということで 心は
あの 輪廻に あるいは存在に
あるいは苦しみに徹底的に結ばれているんです
我々の心はなかなか自由にならないんです
厳密に結ばれているんです
体にしたって 我々体に心は徹底的に結ばれていて
体なしには何も考えることもできないし
頭の中にあるすべての知識っていうのは
単なる体に関するもう感覚だけなんです
大した知識は持ってないんですけどね
それですごく威張ってるんですね
知識人たちが すごい知識を持ってるんです
何の知識を持ってないんだ
ただ体に感じる感覚だけ
なんとかなんとかそれで概念化してね
それでまあ囲碁みたいにいろいろ遊んでるだけのことで
駒は前に置いた 後ろに置いた
横に置いたとかね だから何でか
全部ただの駒 上前後ろ下動くだけのことで
ですから この我々の知識にいたっては
全部もう体に関する事だけです
で ですから 心っていうのはそういうふうに体に厳密に結ばれているんですね
そういう働き この心の働きを理解しないと
解脱の道というか 心自由なる道っていうのはありえない
心の次元を乗り越えると
普通の生命として生きることは乗り越えることはできないんですね
で それから説明出ますけど
例えば人間の一番悪い束縛
人間一番悪い誤解っていうのは
我々は人間だということなんですね
すごい偉いと思ってるんですね
ですから 自分たちが全部知っている
人間の角度で全世界 全宇宙
宇宙全部理解してやればいいんじゃないかと
それ全てが知っている
それ単なる人間に見えることだけで
人間の体で感じる感覚しか何もないんですね
違う体持ってる人にとっては違う感覚生まれるんだから
違う知識 違う宇宙観 違う存在感が生まれてくるし
だからそれ全然何の意味もない考え方なんですね
ですから 仏教でサッター衆生
あるいは有情というふうな一言葉で
全生命を一言葉でラベリングしているんですね
梵天であろうが 神々であろうが
もう誰であろうが 人間であろうが
動物であろうが 有情ですよと
サッターですよと サッターっていうのはこのいろいろ定義ありますけど
この囚われているものよという意味なんですね
存在に囚われているんだからサッターと言うんだと
日本語の漢字は別に意味を通じていないんだけど
それでも有情という場合はね
情があるという感じでしょうかね
衆生 ですから そういういわゆる感情のみ
何のこともないと ですから別に動物と人間っていうのは何の差もないんです
衆生差有情だけですから
アメーバと私たちはどこが違いますか？でも体は違うだけなことで
体違うんだから アメーバ知る世界と我々知る世界は違うかもしれません
どっちが正しいか どうやって言うんですかね
言えません 何も で 我々の細胞がたくさんあるんだから
私たち知ってる世界正しい
それだったら あの 何て言いますか
イルカとか あの それからクジラとかね
もっと大きい体持ってるんだから
もっとたくさんのこと知ってるでしょうよ
クジラの脳にしたって人間のよりはかなり大きいし
だから確実にもっと違う世界を知ってるはずなんです
イルカにしたってもね
まあ視覚ではなくて あのー
ラダーで 音で音でちゃんと見えますから
音で見える世界っていうのはまたすごい違う世界ですよね
でしょうね ですから この我々に見えるのはね
ほんのこの前のね 度ぐらいの角度で物しか見えませんし
あのカエルみたいな目が飛んでると
もうちょっと幅広く見えるかもしれませんだけど
それもそうじゃなくて
前にもう中に入ってるんだからね
なかなか角度も狭いし
イルカなんかには度周り全部見えますからね
後ろ見えますから ですから
この そちらの視覚はまた違うしね
どちらが正しいかっていうことはまあはっきりないことで
人間というのはやっぱりそういうふうに思ってる
それも一つの心の働きなんですね
私たちは全部知ってるんだっていうことをね
それでどうなった 結果としてどうなってるかというと
何も知らなくなっちゃうんですね
私たちは全部知ってるんだと思ってるんだから
知ろうとしないんですね
自分の角度でしか 自分に見える世界しか見ようとしない
それこそ無知の道なんですね
そういうわけで 仏教の世界というのは
もういとも簡単に人間の知識を乗り越えて
もうどんな問題あったでも簡単に解決できるようになっているんですね
ですから この心の真相
このの心所を勉強しただけですべての心の働きをわかったわけにならないんです
それぞれの心所が時々違う働きをする
例えば放射線にしたっても
それはすごい悪いものだと
そう言い切れないんですね
原子爆弾みたいなものを起こしちゃって
もうコントロールなしに放射線をあっちこっち行って行ったならば
それはすごく悪いもので
でもきちんとコントロールして量とちゃんと的を当てて放射線を使うと
我々治療に使ってるんですね
同じ危ないもの ですから放射線は同じガンマ線かいろいろありますけどね
同じ放射線なんですけど
ある時はある働きをするし
ある時は違う働きをするし
ですからその ことを勉強しなきゃいけない
それでガンタっていうのは徹底的に結ぶ
つくということで 我々はすごくこの輪廻に
存在に縛られている それでどこで縛られているかと
心のどんな感情で我々は輪廻に縛られているかっていうところで
四つ仏教で言ってるんですね
いわゆる人間に解脱できないといえば
この四つだけというわけじゃないんです
このガンタ 結びといえば
結んでる結びといえば
この四つですよと で くびきという言葉あったらしいね
くびきといえばまたこういう四つですよ
だからこの ちょっと言葉の意味がちょっと違うだけで
くびきといえば やっぱり結ばれていて
自分が自由に歩いたいんだけど
やっぱりもう大変な邪魔者を引っ張っていかなくちゃいけない
だからどこ行ったっても自由がないんですね
くびきという場合は そういう風な解釈になる
ですから 心は自由になりたいんだけど
どこかで足を引っ張られている
それは四つあるんだと
くびきの場合はね そこで結ぶという場合はそうじゃなくて
まあほんのちょっとニュアンスが違う
自分がもうこれに これに結ばれて
こういうわけがあるんだから
出て行けませんよと と人が言うような感じなんですね
私の足にこれがついてるんだから
手にこれついてるんだから
首にこれついてるんだから出ていけませんよと
本人が出て行きたいがなかとる
また別の話で それは言い訳にして出て行かないようにする
出て行ったっても くびきの場合は出て行ったっても
どうぞ行ってくださいったっても
これもうつなげているんだから
もう連れて行かなくちゃいけない
だから自由になるということはない
そういうふうにこの言葉を変えているのは
そういう風にこの感情のいろいろ働きによって我々はとらわれている
で くびきは四つ  1番目はアビッジャカヤ・ガンタ
そのアビッジャというのは
まあ一般的に言えば欲なんです
心祖の中で欲という言葉で出た
ローダという言葉で出た同じ心祖なんですね
ですから 本当のところはローダ
アビッジャっていうのは同じものなんです
同じものなんですけど
で このエネルギーとして見ると
ローダっていうのは これは一般的な言葉で
ご飯と言えば人は食べるものというふうなもので
でも今日はご飯に あの
何でしたっけ そば食べましたと言うと
また違うでしょうに そばもご飯なんですけどね
ご飯と一般的な言葉で言うならば
で また違うように言えば
ご飯と言えば まあ米炊いたものになると
ライスになるんだと 言ったっても
ただそのいろんな ね ご飯のライスの食べ方あるでしょうに
ですから まあそうすると形が違うんですね
チャーハンにして食べたって
食べているのは同じライスなんですけど
やっぱりそれなりに味も働きも感覚も違う
茶碗で白いご飯食べるよりは
で アビッジャという これはイッチャーという言葉がこの中に隠れていて
アビっていうのはレベルが高いということで
いわゆる強力 強力的なという意味なんですね
このアビダルマのアビもおなじみなんですね
方よりはちょっときめ細かく
厳密にやっていますから
アビダルマでは イッチャーという言葉っていうのは欲ですね
そのイッチャーっていうのはすごく欲しがるという意欲
欲っていうのはあまりニュアンス的に悪い意味で取ってないんだけど
すごく欲しがるという意味で
アビっていうのはすごい強力的に欲しがるということ
ですから 欲と言えばそんなにニュアンスが入ってないんですね
アビッジャで言えば その欲がものすごく強力的になって働く場合があるんですね
だから心臓がエネルギーが尽くんですね
例えば努力しましょうと頑張りましょうと言っても
我々はその時その時のその頑張る度合いが違うでしょうに
時々はもう飲まず食わずやっちゃうし
まあ時々はまあそこそこお茶おせんべい食べながら頑張るし
そういうふうにこの私は頑張ってますいたっては
いつでも同じ力強く 徹底的に頑張れってことじゃないんで
そのその目的に応じて頑張るというエネルギーが
まあ心が調節しちゃうんですね
まあそれは普段いろんな人生にもあることで
どんなことにも同じことで
まあ料理作ってますよでいたっても
そのその場合によって料理作ることに絞るエネルギーが変わっちゃうんですね
ですから私はすごい もうなんて言いますか
心込めて料理作ってますよと
作るためにいたっても
いつでも同じく心込めてやるというわけじゃなくて
誰に作るか 何人に作るか
いつ食べるかとかね そういうことによっても自分のエネルギーが変わっちゃうし
で それからいろんなまた材料によっても作るぞというエネルギーが出てくる食材がある場合もあるし
こんなもんかという感じで作る場合もあるし
そういうふうに この心の心臓っていうのは
心臓っていうもののエネルギーも
いろんな時 いろんな時
それなりに変わる ずっと一定してるわけじゃない
そこで漏치가強力化になる
すごい巨大化になったらアビッチャーというんですね
ですから私はアビッチャーはいつでも訳する場合はこの異常な欲と訳するんですね
異常な欲 いわゆるノーマルな欲じゃなくて
ちょっと異常 ですから
この異常な欲 変な欲ですね
いわゆる論理的な合理的な欲じゃないんです
これは論理的な合理的な欲っていうのは何とかできるんです
例えばすごくお腹が空いたと
でもサンドイッチなんかは食べたくないんだと
自分がご飯食べたいと思ったら
それは別に異常な欲じゃそれは異常な欲じゃないんです
で そこら辺に行けばご飯を買って食べることはできますね
ですから なんとかすることできます
で もし同じ人 私はお腹が空きました
空きました 何かを食べたいと
その人のおにぎりを持って
おにぎりなんかは食べたくないんだと
もうなんでもせっかくご飯お腹が空いてるんだから
もっと違うものを食べたいんだと
じゃあそばはどうですか？と
そばなんかつまらないと
じゃあうどんはどうですか？と
うどんなんかもう食べられもうこんなにお腹が空いてるんだから
すぐまたお腹が空きます
もう食べたくないと それでも何も
じゃあうなぎどうですかと
もうこのうなぎ食べる時間じゃないんだと
この時期も違うんだと
そういう風になると どこでその人の問題解決するんですかね
キリがないでしょ その場合は
その場合は お腹が空きました
何か食べたいというこの欲がちょっと異常になってるんですね
どうしようもない状態になってるんですね
それでその人はすごい苦しみを確実に味わう
ですから 例えばお腹が空いて何でもいいんだから何か食べたいという人の場合は欲が弱い
ですから 何でもいいんだからという人が何かあれば
まあこれで十分だと そこで簡単な苦しみで問題が終わる
お腹が空いたんだけど
私はもうそばしか食べませんと
今日はと決めたら もうそば屋さんは探さなくちゃいけないんだけど
1KM以内ではいくらでもそば屋さんは見つかる
そこで 30分並んで待っていたっても
まあ食べることは食べられますね
それでその問題は解決する
苦しみはちょっと多いんだけど
欲がちょっと強いんだけど
解決はする でも 3番目の人はどうすればいいんですかね
どんな店に連れて行っても
その店はちょっと古臭いとか言うならば
じゃあこの店 これはちょっとおしゃれすぎだと
ただご飯食べるためにそんなおしゃれな店に行く必要ないとか
そんなことを言い始めると
もう苦しむだけで終わりがない
そういうふうに この欲っていうのは時々もう何のことなく弱い場合もあって
まああるターゲットがあって欲が生まれる場合もあるし
ちょっとあのコントロールしている綱が切れちゃって
糸が切れちゃって どこでも飛んでいく場合もあります
ですから アビッジャーっていうのは
そういうふうにこのコントロールできない
異常な ノーマルでない
変なおかしい欲なんですね
そういう欲があると 永久的にその人には逃げられないんですね
ですから そのご飯の例ですごい簡単単純な例ですから
あのちょっと考えてみてください
まあ時々そういうふうに
私は分かりやすい例を出さなくちゃいけないんだからね
で まあ子供にセッティングする経験
誰ににもありましたからね
時々子供はそういうふうに欲を出しちゃうんですね
それで何か欲しいんだけど
何ですかとはっきりしない
あげるわけにもいろいろ嫌です
嫌ですと じゃあこれはどうですか？それ嫌ですと
そうすると母親がすごい困っちゃうんですね
どうすればいいか で まあ時々子供はそういう場合はその場合分かりやすいんですね
まあもう子供に別になんか大胆な欲を作ってるわけじゃなくて
もうただ単にその時はアビッジャーが生まれただけ
アビッジャーが生まれて
もう本人も自分でも知らない
何が欲しがってるか そういうターゲットがないんですね
それで二人とも 母親も子供も両方とも困ってしまっちゃう
苦しんでしまっちゃうんですね
ですから この そういう場合は一番分かりやすい答えというか
結論というのは そういう時は答えがないんだと
どうしようもないんだと
その人には救いはないでしょ
どうやってその人救われますかね
救われません ですから
アビッジャーがあると
もう解脱はもう完全にもう不可能
で ですから このアビッジャーを満たすんじゃなくて
アビッジャー自体を消すしかないんです
だから欲を捨てるというよりは
欲は順番に捨てられますから
いっぺんには捨てられませんだけど
まあ自分が何を欲しがっているかというターゲットぐらい絞った方がいくらか楽になっちゃうんですね
そのターゲットもなく
もう欲しがる心のエネルギー
カーヤガンタというまた次のパーリの言葉があります
このカーヤというものはあまり説明してないんです
この本では いくらかの説明あるだろうと思いますけど
こちらナーマカーヤ ルートカーヤ
これ どうやって読むんですか？漢字を
え？ジュ ジュってどういう意味？ん？で
あのカーヤっていうのは時々集まるという意味でも使ってますけど
一応私はもう説明なしに答えだけ言います
注釈書にもないんです
でないのは 当時でそういう言葉がなかった可能性もありますけど
このカーヤというのはシステムという意味なんです
システム 組織みたいに
だからアビッジャーカーヤガンタっていうのは
このガンタは結ぶシステム
異常な欲で異常な欲によって人を輪廻に結んでいくシステムです
働きですね それ一つのシステムです
だから心の中はこのシステムが働く
働いてしまっちゃったら
もう輪廻もできない 自由もできない
もう不自由になって苦しむしか方法ないんですね
ですから 我々の体の中も全部システムでしょうね
消化するの一つシステムで
呼吸は一つのシステムで
血液流れる 血液が流れるの一つのシステムで
それだけじゃなくて 病気になることも一つのシステムなんですね
ウイルスが入る そうすると体がいろいろ決まってる
反応する そうするとウイルスが勝ってしまったら決まってる症状が出てくる
そういうシステムですね
そこで我々の体にがんが出てくるでしょうね
それもがんという組織システムなんですね
そこでがんというシステムが体の中に働き始まる
自分たちには自分たちの自分なりのシステム法則があります
それによって働き出します
そのシステムと体の普通のシステムが合わないんだから
がんが病気だというだけであって
例えば病気になったら我々なんで病気だと言うんですかというと
このウイルスが入って体の中に起こすシステムと
普段我々持っているシステムはちょっと合わないだけ
合わないんだから これは症状だ
病気だという 別にシステムとして見ると
まあ同じ似ている 同じも似ているもないんだけど
ただシステムですね だから体の中で異なっているシステムたくさんついてます
例えば神経システムと血液が流れる
この システムが違うでしょうに
同じ 同じじゃないんだからね
で 似ているところもちょっとあるかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりシステムですね
それで消化システムはどうですかね
全く違うでしょうね ですから
異なっているシステムが一緒に活動する
そこで一緒に活動している
で カーヤ・ガンタという場合は
このアビッジャーというシステム
アビッジャーというあの
輪廻に種子を結びつくシステムというものなんです
だからアビッジャーが生まれた人がとにかく探す
何か欲しいんだから すっごい強力的に欲しがってるんだから
でも何ですかね 欲しがってるの
それわからないんで 本人に
いくらあっても足らないだけのこと
そうすると その人の その人が必死になって対象を
こちら書いてるのは諸縁ですけどね
この諸縁 対象を探すだけ
対象は無常であるということを知って捨てましょうということにはならないんです
ならないし なれないし
そういうわけで 欲が万が一アビッジャーになっちゃったら
もう解脱不可能な状態に心は回転してしまっちゃうんです
そういうわけで 心に欲があったっても
それしょうがないんです
悟らない限りは治らないんです
ですから 我々はどこに気をつけるかというと
私たちは普段持っている欲がアビッジャーに変身しないように気をつけなくちゃいけないんですね
欲は悪性ではないんです
持っている欲が異常な欲にならないように
いつでもちゃんとコントロールしておかなきゃいけない
もし欲がいきなり爆発してアビッジャーになっちゃったら
もう終わり もう解脱できない
だからそれ癌とすごい似ているんですね
癌というのは病気じゃないんですね
ただ 体の細胞がいつでも成長しているんですね
古い細胞が死ぬのは その代わりに新しい細胞が生まれてくる
細胞分裂によって それは別に病気じゃないんですね
そこである日 この個の細胞が自分で分裂する速さが変えちゃうんですね
みんなと同じ速さでやるんじゃなくて
自分勝手にもう増え始めちゃうんですね
自分一人で増え始めるんだから
材料必要でしょうしね
ですから 隣からもう取りたい放題
アミノ酸やら DNA やら何でも取ってしまっちゃう
それで他の組織を侵しながら癌が成長していっちゃうんです
じゃあ がん細胞は正真正銘のその本人の体そのものなんです
体の細胞そのものなんです
ですから 何のことなく素人にも
ちょっと学校でちょっと Biology なんて生物学を勉強している子供たちにでも
がん細胞だったら移植することはできるんです
人の体に 同じ人の体だったら
何のことなく体にすぐ着いちゃって
もう繁殖始まるんです
なぜかというと 全く同じものだからなんです
でも 違う組織を人の体に移植するならば
それは専門家のプロの先生でないと
医者さんでないとできないんです
それには一人だけじゃなくて
医者のグループが来て
いろんな分野での専門家が来て
集めてディスカッションして決めなくちゃいけない
違うものを移植するんだから
ですから 体の持っている体が持っている同じ細胞なんですけど
ほんのちょっとペース
スピードが速くなるという
それだけのことで もうその人は死んでしまっちゃうんです
ですから この欲っていうのはずっと心にあるもので
それはほんのちょっとこの回転が速くなっちゃうと
アビッジャーになってしまう
それで解脱は不可能ということになってくる
それを理解する必要があるということなんです
2番目はアビッジャーの反対の言葉ですから
ヴィーパカでカーヤ・ガンタですね
で これは怒りなんですね
動作っていうのは怒り
それ怒り自体ががんになっちゃったらヴィアーパーダ
異常な怒り 普通でない怒り
変な怒り で コントロールできない怒り
ですから 原因か論理的な考え方から生まれた怒りではないんです
何か人が怒っても まあこういうこういうわけで私が怒りますというならば
その怒りっていうのは
まあノーマルな普通の怒りなんですね
ですから何とかできます
まあ人が自分が怒ったことにそれなりの論理的な原因を持っていると
その原因はなんとかなるならば
あの怒りは自然に消えちゃうんです
そうじゃなくて 欲と同じく
ただもう原因不明 あるいはもう論理的な根拠はない
ただ怒っていると その人にとってはもうその怒りを収める方法はないんです
ですから どのように現れるかというと
例えば私たちが何か原因があって怒ったと
原因というのは 自分の部屋にいる人々はちょっとすごいうるさいんだと
大きな声で喋ってるんだと
仕事ができないと それで怒るんですね
怒ってもそちらにちゃんとした原因があるんですね
そうすると その人は怒鳴るかもしれません
静かにしなさいと それで向こう側を静かにしたならば
あの怒りがそれで終わってしまっちゃうんです
そうじゃなくて 何のこともなく
ただカッとなったと キレたと
それ なんでキレたんですか？それは本人知らない
そうすると その本人にとっては何やってもあの怒りが消えませんね
このキレる現象ね 現代ある
それはヴィアーパーダなんです
理由はない ただもう怒ってしまう
まあ理由はないと言ったっても
全てには理由がありますけどね
です でもそんな簡単に理解できる理由っていうわけじゃないんですね
そこでその人は人殺すはもう他人にも多大な迷惑かけるわ
何をしても本人に怒りが収まることは全然収まりません
できたならばもっとやりたかったんだというぐらいなんです
ですからヴィアーパーダっていうのは
このそういう他人にすごい多大な損害を与える怒り
例えばこの まあとにかく人に損をする
人に害を与える怒りはアビッジャーというんです
ヴィアーパーダというんです
と言っても 私の定義から見ると
例えば自分の家族を殺しちゃったと
誰かが それですごく怒って相手の
殺しちまったと その場合はターゲットあるんですね
ターゲットがあって理由があるんですね
こういう理由で私が怒りましたということ
それで怒った 怒る自分の怒りのターゲットがありますね
私はあの人に対して怒っているんだと
ですから その人を殺すのはその犯人だけなんですね
例えば自分がうちに帰ってみたら
自分の家族みんな殺されていたんだと
誰が殺したとよく知ってるんだと
それでその家族の一人の子供がその時は遊びに行って家にいなかったと
そこで 5時半ぐらいで自分の子供がうちに帰ると
自分がカンカン怒ってるんだから
まずその子供を殺す それはありえないんですね
その人はその子供は殺せない
なぜならば その人はものすごく怒ってはいるんだけど
その怒りにはちゃんとしたターゲットがあるんです
それから原因もあります
そこでもしその人にすごく怒ってるんだから
どうしようもないんだけど
法律的にその人に落ち着きなさいと
それはもう徹底的に法律に任せてください
と言ったら その人はああそうですかと
と言って落ち着く可能性もあります
あなたもできるだけ犯人を探すために協力してくださいと言ったら
それで犯人殺すんじゃなくて
犯人を探すためにじゃあ協力しますという風に
その怒りが抑えていくことは可能なんですね
アヴィッチャーダーはそういうことは不可能なんです
ただもう怒ってる ただ怒ってるんだから
キレてるんだから 誰を殺しても
誰を誰を殴っても どんな家を火をつけたっても
その人の怒りは収めるということはないんです
そういう人に悟られますかね？悟られない
精神的な病気なんですね
その 2つはわかりやすいことですね
3番目と 4番目はもっともっと勉強してほしいんです
シーラッバタ・パラマーサをかえがんと
これもシステムですね
繋げるシステム 天上に
シーラッバタ・パラマーサ
シーラっていうのは戒律の戒
バタっていうのはバタという言葉で言いますけど
これの場合は業 いろいろ業
シーラは戒 バタは業ですね
パラマーサというのは固執すること
固く囚われていること
信じること これはこの神速としてどんな神速かというと
ローバディッティマーナという 3つがありましたね
あの不善心所の中で欲のセットの中